here in the U.S finding enough workers
for nursing facilities can be a big
Challenge and it's an even bigger
problem in Japan which now has the
second highest percentage of its
population that is over the age of 65.
rising from just 5 in 1960 to almost 30
percent today but in one Japanese City
they are enlisting an unusual segment of
society to provide just the help they
need from Nagoya Japan Lucy Craft has
the story
bending lifting and hoisting human
beings again and again physically
demanding even back-breaking labor is an
occupational hazard in nursing care the
world over but at this facility for the
disabled in central Japan the job
description calls not just for working
with clients but working out these
nursing AIDS Moonlight is competitive
bodybuilders easily hoisting weights
several times as heavy as their clients
before or after their six hour shifts
Nursing Care staff required to work out
for two hours at the gym Pumping Iron
augmenting those abs of steel before
they clock out for the day and it's all
on the company dime
I also get a 150 dollar monthly protein
powder allowance said muscle man yuya
Yamamoto all my expenses are covered for
tournament competition is this your
dream job yes Yamamoto is among eight
hunks higher to literally change the
face of Nursing Care One of Japan's
least popular careers
desperate to staff his new nursing care
company entrepreneur yusuke niwa a
weight lifter himself tried a gimmick he
began recruiting muscle men as poster
boys for an unloved profession
at first it was a pure public relations
ploy to get people interested in nursing
care work he said but these guys teach
everyone how to live smart and prevent
injury the bodybuilders went viral
giving the Visionary company Fame
without spending a dime on ads
last year the company received hundreds
of queries for just a few dozen jobs
with a massive nursing staff shortage
forecast by 2040 some of Japan's
brawniest men are lending a hand where
it's needed most
for CBS Saturday morning Lucy Craft
Nagoya Japan
I love the whole premise I mean you get
paid for the workouts yeah you get paid
for the workout well I mean it's like
it's like you get brilliant brilliant